oh good great
we were forced to wait far too long to
see the iconic minions back on the big
screen now that they're here we're
checking out what on Earth was going on
behind the scenes I love the fact that
you start with iconic number one how do
you think Corel manages to do the voice
a lot of helium just to get my voice
now that he's not just voicing Gru but
Lil grew it kind of goes down from this
little Groo hasn't built up walls around
himself yet and hasn't been hurt as much
as his older self so for Steve Carell to
play a younger Gru he found there was an
added sense of Joy to the character and
even the storyline it's pitched and
pinched carella also finds that younger
Guru is just overall far more Earnest
there's a little bit of a Purity to that
character that was fun to tap into like
how freaking adorable is this
number two do you think minionese will
one day be as developed as Lord of the
Rings Elvish
anytime Steve Carell has had to fake
some minions of his own the language
spoken by the minions if you're
unfamiliar with the word and it's really
hard to learn you'd think gibberish
would be super easy to learn oh well
oh my God
number three sometimes having your
homework proofed by children is the best
way to Ace it the first movie came out
way back in 2010 don't you feel old well
so are corel's kids I started these when
they were really little and now they're
not little at all they were like four
and seven years old at the time the
voice that made them laugh is the one
that he ended up using they're the ones
who determined it yeah and his most
Cherished Memories surrounding the
movies actually involved his kids they
had a special premiere of Despicable Me
set up in his kids classroom I can chart
their growth through all of these
different Despicable Me movies and his
son is still a fan man my son is 18 and
he brought a bunch of friends to this
Corel was purposeful in not making his
accent German or French or Italian or
Russian it was just sort of an overview
of all of those countries he likes to
keep it natural too I don't go for this
uh electronic pitching of voices there
will be no Alvin and the chipmunking his
voice number four Julie Andrews was
working from a closet when covet hit
Julie was asked if she could send some
temp tracks from home she's got a
grandson who's an editor and a sound man
her words she said granny I'll build
your little Studio he commandeered an
upstairs closet and turned it into a
makeshift Sound Studio for her while
most people were conducting business
pantsless over Zoom the voice actors
were building blanket forts in their
closets true story and I go in and kind
of throw the last blanket over me and
and practically expire in them number
five even after winning a Lifetime
Achievement Award Julie Andrews still
struggles sometimes Cruise mom is one of
the worst characters you could possibly
imagine she really struggled with
nailing the voice of the character one
of the hardest ones that's the
voiceovers that I've ever done that's
awesome because she's kind of
complicated lady but that doesn't mean
she didn't enjoy the challenge it was a
delight to get my teeth into it I have
to admit number six Taraji P Henson
knows how to make a villain stand out
making them layered is the answer you
can't just play the mean because then if
you turn the people off too soon then
you lost your audience so that means a
delicate balance had to be struck the
best villains are always complex
feels seriously think a puny little
child can be a villain number seven
Danny on the other hand wasn't allowed
to do anything weird since Danny Trejo
had such a distinctive voice he wasn't
allowed to alter it for the cartoon he
was 100 hired for his voice and his
voice alone no pitching he just loves
movies that he can have fun with he
loves movies that don't make you solve a
problem just to watch it so movies like
minions the rise of Gru are perfect for
him well is he the funny guy he just
makes you laugh number eight there was a
ton of improv in the studio it's
different because there's so much of it
is is predicated in imagination too
director Kyle balda said of Steve
Carell's performance that a huge part of
it is ad-libbing and improvisation and
you have to give all sorts of different
options as you're doing it the director
called Corral the custodian for the
character the team invites all the
actors to improvise because you never
know what sort of gems you're going to
find in this spontaneity and it's just
throwing stuff against the wall and
seeing what's what works number nine no
we're not talking about Gru's mom and
her new Guru friend did you know that
the rise of Guru is a love story no well
it is so says the director at the end of
the first Minions movie we saw Kevin and
a young Guru make eye contact this
inspired them towards the next logical
step which was having them navigate
their Newfound partnership then Kung Fu
came in because they just thought it
would be hilarious but at its heart it
truly does follow the plotline of a
rom-com the core of the story is the
minions and grew as balda said it's a
love story they break up get back
together sort of the trials and
tribulations they go through good night
good night yes yes yes good night number
10 animation is a very different beast
from live action with live action you've
got cameras capturing motion sound and
all that fun stuff at the same time with
little room for change after the shoot's
over but animation is like doing all
that but for two plus years and
constantly changing everything in a
chaotic Whirlwind of fresh ideas
director Kyle balda described working on
an animated film as spinning a lot of
plates at the same time because unlike a
live action movie where there's a
logical order to the sequence of things
in animation there's a lot more
flexibility even with things like
scheduling and locations when artists
can work from home we readjust things as
we move along number 11 are you having
Deja Vu like we are we swear we've been
seeing these ads since February
2020. truth be told minions the rise of
Gru was supposed to come out on July 3rd
2020 and advertising had already begun
before the dreaded pandemic came along
director Kyle balda said we only had
about four or five weeks left of
production but that got stretched out a
couple of months so now our dear
anti-hero uh villain turned Hero
whatever you want to call him has his
origin story what more is there to do
we're sure a ton this franchise is far
from done with Corel I'm working on this
Despicable Me 4 right now number 12. a
classic case of write what you know the
location was important to the director
he grew up in Arizona in the desert and
had never been to a big city until he
reached 16. he lived in the Bay Area of
San Francisco and he fell in love with
it immediately so he was just thrilled
he could make that the setting for the
film The
trade my feel my future
for a bat
Batman
a long wait but it's totally worth it to
see that kung fu rabbit action on the
big screen for ourselves what do you
think was it the right move to delay the
movie for two years let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things
good night